thanks to Native for helping support
this episode hey crazies you might have
heard that black holes suck like
literally people love to comment this on
my black hole videos is it a funny joke
yes is it accurate absolutely not black
holes aren't even that weird if you're
far enough away let's correct this and
other misconceptions as I send an
Expendable clone to his Doom wait wait
Expendable clone I didn't I didn't agree
to this
thank you
oh thank goodness you put me in a
spacesuit
don't worry he's safe for now
to be fair some black holes are big like
really big but those are not common
supermassive black holes are not the
norm we certainly have one at the center
of our own Galaxy that has four Million
Suns worth of mass you could fit up to
17 Suns across its diameter and it's
small given the size of our galaxy I
have a video on how those might have
formed if you're interested but galaxies
usually only get one of those and the
most extreme cases they get two some
galaxies don't have any the vast
majority of black holes in the universe
are Stellar Mass black holes our own
Galaxy probably has on the order of a
hundred million and as the name suggests
these are black holes with the mass of a
star the closest confirmed example is
Gaia bh1 it's about 1600 light years
away and has a mass of almost 10 times
the Sun but don't be fooled this thing
has a tiny diameter less than two
percent the size of the Moon
baby baby black hole
ah
do you remember the first time we
detected gravitational waves back in
2015 yeah those came from black holes
that looked like this five percent and
six percent the size of the Moon in fact
given the age of the universe we only
expect to find Stellar Mass black holes
up to about 200 solar masses that makes
for a black hole that's only 34 the size
of the Moon all Stellar Mass black holes
are smaller than our moon most black
holes are small enough to use a city for
scale granted they're still pretty big
by human standards but not
astronomically
do black holes have an insane amount of
gravity yes they do but only if you get
close enough
Expendable clone isn't that close at the
moment he's aware that he's falling
toward something but that's it there's
nothing extreme happening aside from the
lack of light it could just as easily be
a star hello
it's not like black holes have a special
sucking power or something gravity is
still gravity we see stuff orbiting
black holes all the time it's how we
find some of them I mean look at Gaia
bh1 again there's a sun-like star
orbiting it pretty comfortably that's
how we know it's there and ordinary
Newtonian gravity is enough to explain
that orbit the black hole could just as
easily have been a 10 solar mass star
the orbit would have been the same
nothing weird is happening because a
black hole is in control there's no
extra suck it's just gravity
this one is a bit pedantic but worth
discussing a black hole is defined as a
region of space enclosed by an event
horizon it's not the matter that's
collapsing it's the intangible
space-time bubble that's formed around
it a black hole has a finite volume
that's either a sphere or an ellipsoid
black balls in space
and it contains a finite amount of mass
which means its density is also finite
Gaia bh1 still has a pretty high density
at 23 trillion times that of Steel but
it's not infinite and many supermassive
black holes have a density less than air
but what about the singularity okay you
want to get into this let's get into
this Singularity is not a physical term
it's a mathematical term it means a
point in a mathematical function that
outputs an infinite value but Infinity
isn't something we observe in the real
universe so historically singularities
always turn out to indicate one thing
that we've stepped beyond the scope of
our model we don't expect the
singularity at the center of a black
hole to be any different this
Singularity probably doesn't exist but
even if it does it's hidden behind an
event horizon it's not useful to define
a black hole by anything we can't
confirm you're allowed to not like it
but that's how it is
oh man these lights are making me sweaty
good thing I have on my native deodorant
okay with the cheesy transition out of
the way I've got to be honest I'm not a
huge fan of deodorant I only wear it
when I'm going out but this native
unscented deodorant for sensitive skin
is actually decent it's not
antiperspirant so I'm still gonna sweat
but at least I won't smell and the odor
protection on this stuff lasts up to 72
hours
I mean this is the first unscented
deodorant I've used that doesn't
actually smell like anything
I also tried coconut and vanilla and
powder and cotton they're subtle and
non-offensive all Native deodorants are
aluminum and paraben free and their
sensitive line is also baking soda free
if you're interested you should use my
link and enter code the science Asylum
to get 20 off your first purchase at
Native this offer is available site-wide
but only for a limited time so don't
wait too long now back to the black
holes
we said earlier that a black hole isn't
really an object it's a region of space
that region is enclosed by something we
call an event horizon you know how we
can't see past our distant Horizon
because the Earth curves away a black
hole Event Horizon is analogous to that
except its space-time itself that's
curving space time has curved so much in
a black hole that all Futures Point
inward so it's true that nothing can
escape from inside the Horizon but
plenty of things escape from outside
oftentimes we'll find an accretion disk
a collection of in-falling matter that
matter emits all sorts of light and the
magnetic field generated by it can cause
high-speed particle Jets there's also
Hawking radiation which are long radio
waves being emitted by space itself the
region just outside a black hole is
teeming with activity yet we still don't
see any visible light and that's because
of redshift specifically gravitational
redshift if Expendable clone were to
hover above the Event Horizon of a black
hole shining his flashlight out into
space we wouldn't see it the farther we
get from him the more redshifted the
light becomes eventually it shifts into
the infrared a form of light we can't
see
hold me
black holes redshift light into Oblivion
and that's why they're black
tidal forces are what tend to rip
astronomical objects apart I recently
did a video on how this effect can turn
moons into planetary Rings it can happen
with people too if the forces are strong
enough the official scientific term for
this is spaghettification don't let that
name give you the wrong impression
though it might stretch you out but it's
not going to turn you into human
spaghetti it's going to turn you into
human particle bits is that like bacon
bits bacon bits
cute and snack size baggages for your
convenience
nothing to see here
anything falling into a black hole
whether that be an object or a person is
just going to become an
indistinguishable part of the accretion
disc oh that reminds me Expendable clone
is still out there
oh thanks I thought it was Expendable oh
no that's that's just a name you know
for entertainment value well you could
have told me that before you sent me out
anyway black holes are an incredibly
interesting phenomenon but they don't
have to be terrifying as long as you
keep your distance you'll be fine and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy
several of you pointed out that we're
not actually seeing particles yes
technically we're only seeing light
scattering off of tiny alcohol droplets
but those droplets exist because of the
particles we don't ever see particles
directly but that doesn't mean they're
not there anyway thanks for watching